ce qui est bien avec le code de
la route c'est commencer
accessible c'est ludique
cinéma3 en avoir
alors faut savoir que les gens
du code de la route ils ont un
vocabulaire qui en a déjà tous
les gens de la vraie vie on
n'utilise pas déjà dès le
premier jour la dame
d'inscription 10 ans que ces
états tiers
elle m'a posé une question
dans laquelle s'est pas trop
préparé
est-ce que dans le passé vous
avez déjà été motorisés
depuis des mois
donc d'être autorisé ça veut
dire avoir un véhicule avec un
moteur de danse
le foot c'est pas forcément
quand tu pilotes d'un vtt
ce qui était mon cas
ce qui est toujours mon cas
c'est comme le simple mot
voiture 2010par voiture
oui disent pour la série de
questions qui suit
nous imaginons que vous utilisez
un véhicule de tourisme
c'est-à-dire de catégorie 3
ce parti pourra tourner
d'exonération
diplômé bac
sur la route que nous apprenons
maintenant madonna
peu utilisé dans quelques
mètres vous allez rencontrer un
beau talent ou à cassis
un classique
combien de mecs en france tu
dises bakassi
c'est quoi les rangs
personne n'a peut être pas ses
mots divers pas naturel la
caisse ballantine jacques sylla
pour moi l'objectif est simple
c'est comme c'était hier de
passer les cyclistes avec des
distances variables
il ya pas mal de 50
non mais vous croyez vraiment
qu'on va s'amuser à mesurer
c'est quoi ce délire
cela fait aussi débat malgré
la bonne distance d'un an de
prison
à la police
problème dépasse 4
centimètres
suite
je n'ai pas bu sans les citer
calculez autant leurs largesses
dans la voiture
heureusement dans les films
d'action et connaissent pas
comme ça
t'imagines code de la route dans
le film d'action
dans cette situation
j'effectue
arrangements de véhicules en
forme des pays
je fais un geste de courtoisie
à l'automobiliste en face avant
de paniquer comme un malade
mental un étudiant code de la
route s'est soldée par le plus
grand coureur
puis sont venus étayer les
questions c'est plutôt à
l'aise avec le fait de garder la
main
vous êtes sous l'emprise d'un
pétard a pas de base de résine
de cannabis
vous êtes donc sous l'emprise
de la drogue
très important
la spirale parisienne
le gouvernement fait du match il
est vraiment pas bien quand tu
fumes kuti pas bien dans cette
situation
je dépense
je fais tourner
je n'aime pas les couilles
ap
la médiathèque de la retraite
du combattant à tort leur
passion c'est quand même
étonnant
il faut pas l'oublier
on a tendance à l'oublier
des fois je me dis
l'homme s'est fait la voix dans
le dvd du code
les témoins de sa femme le soir
quand ils entrent
oui il pense pas
pour un temps sa femme cette
peut-être la donne si les
questions soulevées
des fois j'aimerais bien qu'à
la place de sergio
l'ol dans les colonnes de so
foot 1000 places de mieux
mercure près de 30 membres sa
page facebook quand même fini d
honneur ça fait tellement
plaisir aux gens je fais un
petit peu pour moi
vous êtes tout de suite